welcome to another episode of modern art
tonight with me
dr. Augustus Ponsonby fan Ponsonby
tonight we are privileged to be hosting
an exclusive private viewing of the
latest remarkable work from the great
maestro the philosopher the poet the spy
and lover known to us only as Polly pie
the man who has quite simply changed
modern art as we know it today these
pictures come from the forthcoming book
this book loves you
a collection of mind-bending genius
which is leading the way in a new global
movement of inspirati this first
painting entitled granny gone postal
demonstrate front beauties exquisite use
of Photoshop and sharpie observe how
pretty pie has layered meaning upon the
meaningless here next we can see how
deftly the great maestro is able to move
from portraiture to traditional still
life in homage to Andy Warhol's great
factory period this piece you are what
you eat
cast a long shadow over the
consumerization of paleo gastronomy our
eyelids delicious
I don't know I never tried one and here
we see cocktail napkin artwork like we
have never seen cocktail napkin artwork
before Peter pies brilliant piece
emergency our swipe is clearly sticking
up a finger too early modernist
minimalism and leaves us with no doubt
that PewDiePie is the Grand Master of
the bureau finally you Neve ADA echoing
some scribbling found within the great
Leonardo da Vinci's notebooks again with
this book loves you you can clearly see
how pudy pie has transcended all the
taboos of school book doodling to create
this masterful work of self reflexive
ISM breathtaking this has been a brief
look inside the pages of Buddha pies
first ever book we at modern art tonight
have no doubt in our mind that as soon
as the book hits the Shelf October 20th
that it will change the world as we know
it forever this book loves you will be
bigger than cheese bigger than Taylor
Swift bigger than
the son